tik-tok came out a mere three years ago
but it has already amassed over 500
million active monthly users so why does
tic toc blow up
[Music]
welcome to hari saw bees first of all
tic toc is perfect for people's relates
to our attention span microsoft's
research has revealed that people's
attention span has decreased from 12
seconds in 2002 only eight seconds in
apparently this is actually less than a
goldfish whose attention span is nine
seconds now this actual of controversy
surrounding these findings suggesting
that this is actually good thing and
things of that nature but either way I
think we can all agree that people get
bored quickly and tick-tock perfectly
Gator stat it's a perfect way to kill a
short period of time like a short car
ride
you're really not to invest in what
you're watching and you can quickly
finish when the time comes it's perfect
for killing short periods of time and
bank can really be credited for starting
a trend of short videos it really
popularized the trend and distinguish
them from other types of videos of
course there's YouTube Facebook and
Twitter which all existed before vine
but why it was really the tipping point
for short videos like less than 6
seconds long vine really made short
video is a large and serious type of
content and for a vine to be good you
needed two things a great idea and then
perfect execution execution was
essential in vines catching on and
really becoming popular but the thing
with the vine was that there was a small
amount of creators who really dominated
this space and most people were just
users but this would all change with
tick-tock as it was easy to use the
mechanics of the app have really made it
very easy to produce videos at first it
was mainly just singing lip-syncing to
songs and lip-syncing to funny tracks of
course if you produce high quality
content you often had better results but
it was really easy for the average
person to pick up you can just pick up
your phone make a quick lip-syncing
video and get a significant amount of
likes it's really not too hard and the
app actually really encourages this
there's really no serious editing
required if you
there are some great high-tech filters
and tons of additions within the app
itself
their sound effects song snippets
special effects and there's even dog
only filters and since a video format is
so short the thing is the video doesn't
have to be perfect either your video and
audio don't need to be top-notch quality
and it's actually more about the content
itself tick-tocks community is very
inclusive and fun and isn't too worried
about small hiccups or issues in your
videos this makes the app pretty much
accessible to everyone and it really
brings out their creativity the app is
home to many niches from many different
communities you have everything from
music dance Beauty sports Fitness
fashion art through comedy anything and
everything you can think of is there and
if it is not there I'm sure that it'll
be welcomed research reviews the use of
social media trends towards more of a
source of entertainment and creativity
rather than a place to share personal
updates tip-top perfectly feeds into
that as it is a very welcoming community
and easy to enter it really provides
everyone with a place to really express
their own creativity for example it may
capture young people's curiosity for new
things by using short video clips report
beautiful things in life it allows
people to tour the world and experience
things that they have never seen before
without even leaving their household
it's short video structure really allows
people to cover a lot of things very
quickly and YouTube there are some
channels that travel around the world
and reveal of unique cultures but with
the nature of the YouTube audience it's
mostly focused on a couple styles of
YouTube videos and it's mostly in
English you have a gaming educational
and informational and entertainment and
so on and so forth YouTube is playing
not a place that connects cultures from
all over the world but tick tock is the
ease of creating videos on how short
they really are makes it very easy for
creators and viewers readers can just
pick up their phone and show something
unique about their culture and viewers
don't need to spend that much time to
understand some unique aspects of the
culture and today pretty much every
significant culture in the world has
their own niche community and it's not
really segmented either people are
exposed to cultures all around the world
you may see a Chinese woman we've
introduced
Chinese clothing you may say Indian
Street food man making food faster than
you can follow or you may just see
American people being American seriously
though
tick tock is a great platform to share
culture all around the world and
interest people the things that they
have never seen before
tick tock really encourages communion
involvement and makes it easy for people
to participate this is especially true
in big stars start or participate in
popular challenges have you ever heard
that tumbleweed challenge while TV host
Jimmy Fallon's one of the first
celebrities to use the app in his show
in November of 2018 as you probably
already guessed this involved the
tumbleweed challenge this involved
people rolling around on the floor
pretending to be a tumbleweed while it
sounds quite weird is very funny and
entertaining actually of course Jimmy
asked his viewers to participate by
posting their own versions of his
hashtag tumbleweed challenge on the
tic-tock app and the chance pretty much
went viral in just one week time there's
8,000 video entries and ten point four
million engagements challenges and
involvement of famous people have really
skyrocketed tik-tok success after Jimmy
Fallon show probably tens and millions
of people were exposed to Tik Tok for
the very first time hundreds of
thousands of people probably checked out
the app and tens of thousands of people
polygons hoped due to all the
aforementioned reasons these are pretty
much the main reasons that Tech Talk is
such a sensational hit but well at last
today
tick tock is at all-time highs and
there's really no reason that I can't
continue to grow and a very well-made
continue to grow but at one point it
will come down
tik-tok is really just entertainment and
it doesn't offer anything outside of
that really if you take a look at a
platform like YouTube you realize there
are a lot of different aspects to it
like educational informational and
thought-provoking videos as well like
the Jubilees videos tik-tok type
entertainment is a very small portion of
youtube actually if you take a look at
another huge social media giant like
Facebook it's pretty much the same case
it's not just for entertainment it can
be used as a business store advertising
and you can grow a huge community on
Facebook
these platforms have sustained growth
for several years and will continue grow
until they pretty much reach every
single person in the world YouTube can
positively help every single person in
the world in some way or form but
tic-tock really can't do that it's
really just for a niche demographic
right now tik-tok is very hot and
everybody ends up grandma are getting
the app but most of these people will
pretty quickly turn back their usual
sources for entertainment like Netflix
or YouTube Instagram is probably the
best example of this a few years after
the app came out pretty much everyone
was using it on a daily basis but now
most people still have an Instagram
account but they only use it here and
there only a niche community actually
uses it on a day to day basis and tick
tock will eventually shrink to such a
niche community now just because I say a
niche community doesn't mean that it's a
small community it's still a pretty big
termini at 28 30 million users or even
more than that
tick tock isn't going anywhere but what
I'm trying to say that it's not going to
keep going until it touches everyone's
life like twitch or YouTube or Facebook
right now it may seem like it's gonna
grow forever but I think that it will
take a path more like Instagram or
whatsapp but that just what I think
makes you comment down below what you
think is going to have to the tick tock
in the future
tick tock took the world by storm with a
very simple idea of making vine creating
and sharing a simple task due to its
great implementation and small time
commitment he has really blown up but as
it doesn't offer any real tangible value
for most people it's user base will
unfortunately eventually peak and come
down to a much more modest number while
tick tock may not become the next
YouTube or Facebook I truly believe that
tick tock will always have its own
sustainable user base and its own
special place but that's all I have for
you guys on tick tock make sure to
comment down below what company you
would like me to cover next also if you
guys like this video they mentioned up a
like and consider subscribing if let's
see more videos just like this one but
until then I'm Hari I'll see you guys on
next one